[Musica]
[Applauso]
ci sono persone nel mondo così affamate
che dio non può apparire loro se non in
forma di pane
sabato scorso ero a casa in relax e ho
deciso di preparare l'impasto per una
pizza del resto temo non si esca vivi
dal tunnel del lievito di birra che si è
aperto con il lock down insomma preparo
questo impasto lo metto in forno a
lievitare e decidono di invitare due
amici a cena a casa nostra per la sera
successiva la domenica
saremmo dovuti essere quattro quindi una
pizza bella grossa poteva bastare più
tardi mi telefona mio fratello e come
spesso fa si autoinvita a cena a casa
nostra con la compagna sempre per la
sera successiva la domenica
quel pomeriggio insieme alla mia
famiglia vado al mercato e incontro una
coppia di amici che non vedevamo da
tempo con i loro due bambini presi
dall'entusiasmo e un po sopra pensiero
invitiamo anche loro a cena a casa
nostra sempre per la sera successiva la
domenica
come se non bastasse domenica mattina mi
telefona la mia amica cate e con la
scusa che mangiare da sola la domenica
sera le mette tristezza si intrufola
anche lei nella nostra cena a quattro
saremmo stati tantissimi
e io avevo preparato l'impasto soltanto
per una pizza che fare beh innanzitutto
trasliamo questo mio penoso esempio
personale a livello globale secondo le
stime ufficiali delle nazioni unite nel
2050 la popolazione mondiale sarà
aumentata del
25,6 per cento rispetto al 2020 per
capirci meglio immaginate se invece che
in questo palazzetto ampio e arioso
fossimo sempre noi queste 500 persone ma
in un piccolo teatro di paese al
completo e che improvvisamente da 500 ci
ritrovassimo in 630 oppure per fare un
altro esempio pensate se la classe di
vostra figlia fosse composta da venti
bambini e bambine e improvvisamente con
uno schiocco di dita e a parità di
banchi e sedie si ritrovassero in 25 e
nel 2100 con un aumento della
popolazione previsto dal 43,6 per cento
in quel teatro da 500 ci ritroveremmo in
720 in quell'aula da venti bambini si
ritroverebbero in 29 impressionante e
come faremo a sfamare tutte queste nuove
persone che abiteranno il nostro pianeta
da poco tempo come faremo con quella
sola pizza da 4 a dare da mangiare a
molte più persone
per rispondere partiamo da una data una
data molto importante il 16 di ottobre
il 16 di ottobre è una delle date
fondamentali per l'umanità infatti è
nata mia figlia ed era la potete vedere
la in fondo nel passeggino no scherzi a
parte il 16 di ottobre e dal 1979 la
giornata mondiale dell'alimentazione
una giornata creata dalla fao per
celebrare la propria nascita come
agenzia delle nazioni unite ma
soprattutto per sensibilizzare
l'opinione pubblica sui temi della
sicurezza alimentare e dello spreco di
cibo già perché proprio il cibo sarà uno
dei problemi più grandi connessi a
questa rapida e imminente crescita
demografica
aumento della popolazione infatti
significa aumento della richiesta di
cibo che si va ad affiancare ad una
fetta già grande della popolazione
mondiale che oggi soffre la fame fame o
come preferisco chiamarla io
denutrizione e malnutrizione
che negli ultimi due anni il covip la
crisi economica e sociale conseguente ma
anche l'accelerare degli effetti
negativi del cambiamento climatico hanno
contribuito a peggiorare
aumento della richiesta di cibo
significa necessità di intensificare la
produzione agricola
in altre parole di darci dentro con
l'agricoltura in ogni parte del mondo ma
sappiamo che sostenere il settore
agricolo significa sostenere uno dei
settori che maggiormente causa in
termini di inquinamento e di emissioni
il cambiamento climatico
e questo terribile circolo vizioso che
lega in un nesso causa effetto
agricoltura e cambiamento climatico non
finisce qui perché l'agricoltura è anche
uno dei settori che maggiormente paga le
conseguenze del cambiamento climatico
pensate allestì cita alternate ai
fenomeni climatici estremi
all'impoverimento dei suoli agricoli la
desertificazione alla propagazione di
malattie e piante piaghe delle piante
nuove tutti fattori che rendono sempre
più difficile per i produttori in
particolare i piccoli produttori portare
a termine il proprio raccolto annuale
soddisfacendo quindi i propri bisogni
alimentari e di reddito
bene ora che anche grazie a questa foto
scattata da un mio collega siamo tutti
abbastanza angosciati e spaventati vi
racconto con delle foto invece un po più
allegre che cosa io noi leo ng le
organizzazioni non governative e il
mondo della cooperazione nel suo insieme
facciamo ogni giorno per provare a
convertire questo brutto e terribile
circolo vizioso in un potenziale circolo
virtuoso
iniziamo il nostro viaggio per produrre
più cibo e di migliore qualità senza
gravare ulteriormente sull'ambiente e
sul pianeta è necessario cambiare
innanzitutto il modo in cui facciamo
l'agricoltura dobbiamo quindi capire
come possiamo produrre bene vi chiederò
di seguirmi in un viaggio intorno al
mondo
e partiamo con un volo che ci porta in
mozambico qui siamo a fianco dei
produttori e delle produttrici con cicli
di formazioni tecniche sui temi
dell'agricoltura sostenibile un tipo di
agricoltura che è in grado allo stesso
tempo di aumentare e migliorare la
disponibilità di cibo e di essere eco
compatibile quindi più amica
dell'ambiente qui facciamo anche i campi
sperimentali ossia dei campi dove
mettiamo a cultura nuove varietà di
frutta di ortaggi di cereali che siano
più resistenti e resilienti agli effetti
del cambiamento climatico e allo stesso
tempo più sostenibili per l'ecosistema
locale il prossimo volo è di breve
durata perché ci spostiamo in etiopia
nelle regioni del sud qua siamo nel wall
aita qui insieme alle cooperative locali
installiamo impianti di irrigazione
goccia a goccia solari non useremo più
quindi le pompe alimentate con i
carburanti fossili ma sfrutteremo il
calore del sole africano per spingere
l'acqua in un impianto efficiente che
permetta ai produttori anche i momenti
di scarsità d'acqua o di irregolarità
delle precipitazioni di continuare a
coltivare il test il tipico cereale
etiope con cui si fa lingera che è
passatemi il paragone del cuore una
sorta di piadina del corno d'africa
per visitare invece la prossima
esperienza il volo che ci aspetta è più
lungo e transoceanico ci spostiamo in
ecuador nella selva amazzonica qui
realizziamo quella che viene chiamato
cambio di coppa nelle piante del cacao
che altro non è che un bel rinnovamento
della piantagione senza la necessità di
spostare la frontiera agricola e quindi
senza dover deforestare si tratta di
fatto di innestare su piante vecchie
malate poco produttive o anche solo poco
resistenti agli effetti del cambiamento
climatico con delle piante nuove delle
nuove varietà di cacao che siano più
resistenti e più ecocompatibili
permettendo quindi ai produttori di
continuare a coltivare il cacao che una
delle fonti di reddito più importanti
per quella regione e con questo viaggio
in america latina abbiamo introdotto un
elemento importante per la nostra
riflessione di oggi la foresta per
parlarne più approfonditamente dobbiamo
tornare in africa e questa volta
vogliamo in kenya qui da tanti anni
supportiamo programmi di riforestazione
in cui sono proprio le comunità locali a
farsi carico della salvaguardia della
foresta e della preziosissima
biodiversità locale
siccome però molte famiglie molte
comunità vivono o quantomeno vivevano
dei proventi derivanti dal taglio delle
a me è stato necessario in parallelo
supportare anche quelli che si chiamano
prodotti forestali e diverse dalle
niamey quindi attività quali
l'apicoltura e la frutticoltura in grado
di garantire un reddito alle famiglie
che non saranno più costrette a
disboscare per vivere
però per tornare al nostro quesito
principale per produrre più cibo
salvaguardando se possibile anche il
nostro pianeta non basta produrre bene
bisogna rendere più sostenibile anche il
resto della filiera
bisogna quindi anche trasformare bene
essiccare bene con delle serre solari
che sfruttino la potenza del sole
tostare macinare e impacchettare bene
con macchinari ecologici possibilmente
alimentati con gli scarti di produzione
pensate che qui siamo di nuovo in
ecuador siamo riusciti a ottenere dalle
bucce del caffè e dagli scarti della
frutta della palma da olio dei
mattoncini con i quali alimentiamo
questa toast atrice che oltre a emettere
molti meno gas serra rispetto alla sua
omologa che funziona con carburanti
fossili anche un costo di tostatura
orario molto più basso andando quindi a
incidere positivamente sull'economia
famiglia delle famiglie locali
alla fine di questa filiera però bisogna
anche cucinare bene è per questo che da
tanti anni le organizzazioni non
governative sono impegnate a diffondere
questi sistemi è che vengono definite
cucine migliorate ossia dei sistemi di
cottura che utilizzano molta meno legna
rispetto al tradizionale metodo di
cottura africano che invece utilizzare
una enorme quantità di legname
costringendo quindi le famiglie a
deforestare
però vi chiedo non manca qualcosa alla
fine di questa filiera
abbiamo prodotto abbiamo trasformato
tostato essiccato macinato impacchettato
abbiamo persino cucinato parliamo di
cibo da un po e la domanda mi sorge
spontanea ma quando si mangia già perché
fino adesso vi ho raccontato che cosa
facciamo noi che cosa fa la cooperazione
internazionale peraltro si imposti belli
ma non proprio dietro l'angolo quindi mi
domando e noi
che cosa possiamo fare noi
noi possiamo scegliere ogni giorno di
mangiare meglio per mangiare tutti e
possibilmente salvare anche il nostro
pianeta come beh possiamo partire da
alcuni brevi e semplicissimi consigli
che ci ricordano come anche fare la
spesa e mangiare siano azioni di lotta
less is more compriamo meno e meglio
sprecando meno
km zero compriamo vicino
supportiamo l'economia locale equo e
solidale qualora non si possa comprare
vicino pensate ad esempio alla frutta
tropicale al caffè o al cioccolato
compriamo nel rispetto dei diritti di
chi produce questo nostro cibo filiera
corta compriamo prodotti meno
trasformati sfuso compriamo prodotti
meno impacchettati bio e organico
compriamo prodotti meno trattati più
rispettosi del suolo e che evitino lo
spreco dell'acqua se poi ci sentiamo
proprio virtuosissimi e vogliamo
esagerare
compriamo in gruppo chiede qua in
trentino non conosce i gruppi di
acquisto solidale compriamo da aziende
che utilizzino le energie rinnovabili
compriamo da aziende che siano etiche e
certificate e quando facciamo turismo
rivolgiamoci a ristoranti hotel e
attività turistiche che rispettino una
buona parte dei principi che abbiamo
elencato sin qua
ecco quando vi capiterà di sentirvi
piccoli
impotenti
sopraffatti dai macro problemi
dell'umanità la fame la povertà
l'inquinamento le migrazioni forzate gli
effetti nefasti del cambiamento
climatico ecco fate come me
respirate e concentratevi su questa
frase agisci come se quel che fai
facesse la differenza la fa
grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]